salut maxime est ce que tu peux nous
parler de la french tech là on est sur
le salon l'ifa ont bien précisé à berlin
la french tech est présente il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises et est ce que tu
peux nous présenter un peu ce qu'il a
french state ce que vous faites et puis
un petit peu les entreprises qui sont
présentes
après ce texte c'est là la mission
économique de l'état français qui
regroupe toutes les entreprises
françaises qui travaillent dans la tête
non j'ai re particulièrement le lie au
tiff toute cette start-up que tu croises
un peu sur le
le salon est l'idée tu vois on a
construit un pavillon français on a fait
un peu court
durant lequel un jury a choisi une
dizaine de start up innovantes et qui
ont un avenir
potentiel à venir sur le salon on
pourrait des clients des distributeurs
normalement tu as un peu les meilleures
boîtes françaises du moment et ça c'est
assez facile et
dentelle
tous ces votes là tu as dû dériver
connectés
des boules musicale elle tu as faim de
capteurs pour le sport des bijoux on
nettoie on a même des distributeurs pour
les chats c'est le décor c'est quoi la
tendance peut se prononcer dans les
entreprises françaises qui se déplacent
qui sont présentes au sol après ne
serait qu est ce qu un domaine qui est
plus présent qu'un autre n'ont pas
réellement
on a la chance en france d'avoir un
écosystème qui est extrêmement grand
avec des boîtes incroyable et du coup on
trouvera un peu tous les marchés
évidemment tu as des tendances globales
que son intelligence artificielle
je suis
j'ai des bois le français ce qu'ils sont
énormes là-dedans vraiment audible et
aigle aulas mais après en start up plus
réaliste âge on peut avoir des
des objets pour la maison
le marché de l'est
des animaux est incroyable on se rend
pas compte mais ça fonctionne
extrêmement bien
vraiment de tout j'ai les français et ça
c'est une énorme force ok cool
alors du coup
expliquer donc l'apprennent stagne ou
regrouper toutes ces entreprises
innovantes qui sont en train de se
lancer ici à l'ifa vous allez aussi à
vegas ocs qu'est ce que vous faites en
dehors des salons et de quelle manière
vous les accompagnez déjà avant même
d'aller au cs fait le wat ce mythe à
lisbonne auquel énorme salon de start up
et le soul wash qui est le futur
ou est ce mythe est lui le seul achat
lieu à helsinki est effectivement en
janvier on revient en force au csr avec
un nombre mais incroyable de start-up
présente sur le rica parc
est à noter d'ailleurs que à l'ifa les
français c'est la première délégation
maintenant j'en est le premier pays à
venir mais surtout on est les plus
représentés d'accord cocorico
cocorico et après en dehors on
accompagne
régulièrement les entreprises françaises
en essayant d'obtenir des rendez vous
avec des investisseurs qui pardon des
distributeurs on les aide à découvrir
des marchés à l'international
tout au long de l'année avec d'autres
programmes gérés par business d'accord
business france dont vous avez vraiment
un rôle auront comme une couveuse pour
les aider à se développer et à les
emmener à développer leur business
je ne mettrai pas à la couveuse c'est
plutôt l'inversé
c'est de les supporter on supporte ayant
dans l'église demandant leur expansion à
l'international
ok par tous les moyens possibles s'il ya
des entreprises innovantes qui font pas
partie de la french tech mais qui
veulent nous rejoindre pour bénéficier
d'un service qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'elle
vaut frère me contacter voyez vous
mettre en regard de la description bien
sûr
faut nous contacter ça peut passer par
des événements ça peut passer par des
réunions et surtout on peut se
rencontrer physiquement pour en discuter
on a la chance aussi chez disney se
penche la voir l'un deux services
différents
aider des entreprises sur plein de
domaines différents on trouvera la bonne
personne le bon interlocuteur pour le
bon marché ça vole je te remercie
beaucoup avec grand plaisir
et puis on se retrouve sur le site de la
french touch mais dans les descriptions
aller voir tout ça et puis n'hésitez pas
à marquer en commentaire ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous connaissez les
entreprises innovantes
est-ce que ça d'ailleurs vous vous
abonnez entreprise vous avez un projet
création d'entreprise allez voir la
french tech vous mettez tout sens
commente t on enfin très bientôt
merci beaucoup moi je vous dis à bientôt
sa lutte à l'est
[Musique]